hi scalable algorithms for thank you
this talk is about using a supervised
learning doing supervised learning via
boosting and particularly it's about
using parallelism to find optimal weak
learners from a particular class of weak
learners Anita in the last talked
yesterday gave a nice tutorial about
boosting and that's a good thing because
I know almost nothing about it we were
just looking for an interesting example
to test the scalability of our peril
branch and bound solver and then by nice
coincidence this application fit the
topics of this workshop my colleague
Jonathan X sine did all the lifting in
this case not just the heavy lifting so
for the input we're given a binary
matrix the rows of the binary matrix
correspond to observations and the
columns correspond to features and then
each of the rows is also is classified
as in or outside of the class a positive
or a negative example so for example the
Rose could correspond to people and the
columns could correspond to their
individual genetic traits or habits and
symptoms and then the the class could
correspond to whether or not they have a
particular disease now they also have
some weights and i should say we're
going to be there's going to be a fair
amount of notation here but i know this
is after lunch and everyone's going to
be doing a faceplant soon so I'm also
going to try to say English for
everything even though I'll also have
the math represented for clarity and for
people who think better in math and in
words ok so in the we're actually
interested in finding by in finding
binary monomials so binary monomial is
better known in the computer science
world as the claws of a SAT problem so
we specify a particular subset of the
features that we want to appear in the
positive sense a particular subset we
want to appear in the complemented sense
and we could then think of the binary
monomial if you eat the excise or binary
variable 01 then it becomes binary
function so it's the product of the
values of the variables that we want to
appear as
one or as positive times the product of
the 1 minus the variables that we want
to be negated or complemented and so so
then we say that a monomial covers a
particular vector if it agrees on all of
the particular sub pieces of this clause
so if it's one where it's supposed to be
one if it's zero where it's supposed to
be zero so here's a particular example
using the matrix we had in the beginning
if we have if we'd like X 12 B 1 and X 2
to be 0 then J the class of positive
features is one see the class of
complement it features is too and in
this particular case the first and
fourth vectors don't match that but the
other ones do so that's how you pick out
the covered variables and the maximum
monomial agreement problem is to try to
pick out a subset of the features
positive and negative that amongst the
coverage variables maximally
distinguishes between the positive and
the negative examples so in this
particular case here you know in this
particular example if we want x 12 B 1
and X 2 to be 0 we look at the three
vectors that correspond to it and we
consider their weights and we look at
the difference between the weights of
the positive examples and the sum of the
weights of the negative examples this
particular one doesn't have much
discrepancy in fact it's 0 but it was
the only one that had more than one
interesting coverage for the four two
columns so why are we interested in
monomial agreement it's because of a
particular type of boosting that's based
on linear programming called LP boost so
the way that boosting works is you
create a classifier from a common convex
combination of weak learners which might
not individually be doing much but as a
whole in the proper combination do a
good job of distinguishing positive and
negative examples so you start off with
nothing and then you add a particular
class of fire and a weak learner and
and you you do so you you figure out
where your problems are you add weights
based up on where you are right now and
you just iterate until eventually you've
added enough weak learners to have a
good classifier and LLP boost is based
on solving this linear program where r 0
corresponds to the discrepancy or the
distance that you want to have between
the positive and negative examples
you're allowed to have some air and
there's a penalty in the objective
function for that error where D tends to
be small this is the convex combination
so you solve this linear program then
you use the dual variables to wait the
next set and then the separation which
is actually a column generation the way
you find your next week hypothesis or
your next week learner is to solve this
maximum monomial agreement problem due
to we would like to solve it exactly
because Goldberg and Shawn in 2007 said
that if you use some use an exact
separation at least in certain parts of
the computation rather than heuristic
you tend to get better classifiers at
least in certain instances so we're
going to solve the problem exactly using
branch and bound this is a classic
method that one finds exact problems for
combinatorial problems exact solutions
to combinatorial problems in particular
this is the way one solves integer
programs in codes such as grow b or c
plex so in we are trying to maximize a
particular function over a set of
feasible instances normally this is
expressed as a minimization problem but
because we're doing maximum oniel new
agreement I'm going to switch everything
and hopefully get it right in real time
so in a generic branch and bound solver
in order to customize it to the
particular problem you need to come do a
few things the first is to come up with
a problem representation and then you
have to define several different methods
you need to be able to create an upper
bound we're given a set of feasible
solutions that's represented in some
compact way you find a bound such that
the actual value in this case of the
discrepancy is guaranteed to be below
that for anything within that sub region
you also have to be
generally good idea to have a heuristic
method perhaps to round or to find a
feasible solution from any particular
instance and in particular you need to
be able to recognize a single solution
whether it's feasible or not and finally
you need to be able to give in a
particular subset of the feasible region
intelligently split it into partition it
into smaller pieces so here's how
branch-and-bound works generically you
start off at the root problem which is
your initial problem you find the upper
bound that's the upper bound on the
whole problem in the root and you try to
try to find a heuristic solution if
that's possible maybe it comes from the
bounding procedure maybe it comes from
something separate and if they happen to
match then you're really lucky you found
the optimal solution you go home and of
course that never happens so instead
once you've you then instead partition
the region into two sub problems and
then you recurse and then because of
course looks like exponential growth and
it is and it would be in the worst case
because this is the way you tend to
solve np-hard problems and maximum
monomial agreement tends to be is
np-hard but there are three there are
four possibilities when you create these
subproblems only one of which is bad
even though this is most common cases
that you just simply have to continue to
recurse you're not done yet but it's
also possible every time you divide this
region you add constraints to the
subproblems and sometimes those
constraints are incompatible so you
could create an infeasible instance
which you can throw away right away the
other possibility is that you create a
solution where the upper bound matches
the feasible a feasible solution you
found from that region so you're done in
that region and alternatively if you
have an upper bound for the region
that's worse than abound the best found
that you found anywhere in your search
then you know that nothing in it is
interesting you can throw it away that's
called phasma fathoming and in order for
this to work in other words in order for
this tree to actually terminate in a
reasonable amount of time you need to
have good upper bounds one nice property
about branch and bound is that you can
always tell approximately how well
you're doing because the best solution
you have in hand gives you a lower bound
on the problem and if you look at the
set of
open problems in the search tree called
the frontier if you look at the maximum
upper bound that gives you an upper
bound on the whole problem and so in
general you can stop the solution early
if you have a relative gap that you're
happy with say ninety five percent of
the best solution so now we're going to
talk about customizing branch and bound
to this particular maximum monomial
agreement problem and we found this was
a particularly interesting problem
because the serial code had already been
done by Jonathan and a student known
Goldberg so first you need to find
representation and their presentation is
really easy you just partition the set
of features into four classes the ones
that have to be one that's j the ones
that have to be zero that's see the ones
you can't use that's easy eliminated
variables and the ones you haven't
decided on yet and that put completely
partitions the set so any partition is
possible of course they're not the same
quality but it has a nice property and
then furthermore for any particular
representation this JC EF we can
evaluate the objective function on this
set J&C and that will give us a feat
that will give us a feasible solution
and so this is a nice situation that
doesn't normally happen for most branch
and bound problems and in particular
when the when the undecided class F goes
to empty then we only have one element
it's a leaf and that's where you can
that's where you can terminate the
search so first of all let's find out
let's find an upper bound so this F of E
of JC was the difference between or the
absolute value of the difference between
the covered positive examples and the
covered negative examples and so a
really simple upper bound is just take
the maximum of those two okay so that's
nice but we can be we can do a better
job than branch and bound once we decide
put some things in the eliminate and
eliminated set we can be a little bit
smarter so in the eliminated class of
variables if we throw these columns out
let's say e is x2 and x4 and then do
radix sort on the remaining columns the
ones that are now equivalent except for
differences on the eliminated set form
an equivalence class for each
equivalence class everything in that
equivalence class is either covered or
not covered so we can treat them as a
group so let's see here we go so we're
going to this is the notation year for
we were rigidly cared whether they were
positive and when they work whether they
were covered now we additionally care
what equivalence class they're in so we
break them up by equivalence class and
whether they're positive so they have to
be covered they have to be positive or
negative that's going to split them up
and then they also have to be in a
particular equivalence class so you get
a stronger upper bound this way for for
each of the equivalence classes there's
a positive found and a lower bound and
you take the highest of that which means
the weakest of that so in this
particular case we if this sum is
positive then we added in and if it's
negative we just have it a zero that's
what the plus means and we can do this
for the positive side you do this for
the negative side that doesn't mean it's
achievable that's that's why we have an
upper bound something that's easy to
compute and that we know is a valid
upper bound and is generally not
achievable but this allows us to
leverage the eliminated class in order
to get a stronger per pound ok and then
is a more convenient form here a little
bit of algebra will show you which I'm
not going to put you to sleep with here
is that you can start off with the
original week bound and subtract this
min per equivalence class and the nice
way to the reason that we express it
that way is that it's relatively easy to
compute this initial part you're just
doing repetitive intersections of sets
that get smaller and smaller and tends
to be fairly fast so if you can fathom
the problem it that way if you already
know the upper bound is so bad that you
can throw it away then you don't have to
do the more complicated second part of
it and if you do need to fathom it then
you can do the second part
so now how do we branch well it's really
easy that's kind of that's another nice
way of expressing it if I'm in a
particular node and i would like to
partition the region so here these are
the ones that have to be one the ones
that have to be zero the ones that can't
be there the ones we haven't decided on
we pick one of the ones we haven't
decided on and we try it in each place
try it as one try it as a zero try it is
being thrown out and this is the one
that's that's most expensive to compute
the new bounden because that affects the
equivalence classes and you have to
recompute them the Goldberg and Eckstein
did consider a larger multi-way
branching and this particular one gave d
better bounds and and better performance
it created more nodes but since we're
going to be running in parallel on a
massively parallel machine extra nodes
is actually the thing for scalability so
we chose the syntheses eous form of
branching so one other thing you have to
do when you branch just decide which
branch which is the of the variables
that are undecided you're going to
branch on so for this we do strong
branching so for each of these possible
f's we compute each of these bounds we
put them in a triple sorted by their
value and then we do a lexicographic
sort and we take you take the smallest
one and the nice thing about actually
doing this is it also gives us an even
stronger bound that also depends on F
which is the minimum over all f of the
maximum of these values this is called
the look-ahead bound so we can also use
that it bounds the parent and that and
then all the children the nodes
underneath it inherent that bound okay
so now we now that we've decided how
we're going to implement these we
actually ran it in system called pebble
are massively parallel branch and bound
solver peril stands for parallel
enumeration branch and bound library
we're gonna talk about enumeration later
first of all we're just going to talk
about finding a single optimal solution
this is a distributed memory system is
based over MPI and
it's used as C++ so that we can just use
inheritance to customize for a
particular problem that we're trying to
solve this was not bebel was not the
first and it was not the only branch in
peril branch and bound solver but it's
arguably the most scalable one right now
okay so one of the reasons that was
really nice that we already had the
serial implementation of the MMA
algorithm is because para because pebble
makes it so easy to to take advantage of
the heavy duty a parallel aspects of the
code that's hidden or hidden within the
C++ framework from the user you can
override a lot of things but if you
choose not to override it if you have a
decent debug serial application you can
get up and running in parallel really
easily because of this diamond hierarchy
so this is part of the course Oliver
this is part of the course Oliver if
you've got the serial application you
can create a parallel application by
inheriting from both the parallel core
and the serial application and the only
thing that you need to do is is to
create an as to create a function that
tells you how to create a message buffer
that holds the subproblem information
and the base of global problem
information and within pebble there's a
particular data structure called a
packet buffer I like to think of as a
suitcase you put it on your bed you
throw things into the into the end of
the suitcase you don't care about what
the type is at the other end you just
need make sure you unpack corruptly
makes things very easy for starting
things up now you can also take
advantage of parallelism by by doing
some problem specific parallelism if
it's beneficial for your problem I don't
have time in this talk to go into all of
the features that pebble has for doing a
fast peril branch and bound I will talk
about a couple of them in particular
because we want to run on very big
machines we do do checkpointing we do do
early output that means that every once
in a while you save the best solution
you found sort of them if the machine
crashes or if you've been stuck forever
at three percent and you set your bound
at two percent you can just
with what you have so there's also
because this is a an asynchronous code
and there are lots and lots of
processors and lots and lots of various
problems that are communicating with
each other a synchronously termination
is challenging and so I don't time to
explain it but correct it does provably
terminate correctly and that was an
issue for a while okay so one particular
problem that you have when you're doing
a branch and bound tree and you have ten
thousand processors is it starts at one
node at the root and if you have ten
thousand processors you have 999
thousand you know 9999 that aren't doing
much at the beginning so how can you
take advantage of that parallelism until
the tree grows large enough to be able
to have the fairly obvious new level
parallelism so we have something called
a ramp up phase and in the ramp up phase
you allow all the processors to work
together on a single node and they grow
the tree kind of in lockstep until you
have a switch over so there are a number
of things you can do you can do
pre-processing if you can if you have a
kernel ization operation you can work on
more difficult bounds than you would be
doing on an individual processor but in
particular for the MMA we do this strong
branching so at the root where you have
the most undecided nodes and you have to
decide what to branch on and the upper
bound doesn't match the lower bound of
course then you can take all of the
undecided variables split them evenly
amongst the processors if you know if
there's more than enough to go around
each of them individually computes the
it computes the strong branching the
basically and then you do a parallel
reduced to find the one that's going to
do the best job of moving the upper
bound and then you also do another
parallel reduced to compute the
look-ahead bound so right this is what
we're saying we're doing this I just
described in English before I moved over
to the slide so then eventually when
there's enough tree enough nodes in the
tree you want to switch over to the I
guess i call it the cleaner level of
parallelism where instead of working in
parallel a single note processors
individually
process the nodes because the tree is
what's going to grow in an unbounded way
and so in general there are ways that
you can do that when you run out of
parallelism when the number of problems
is large enough in this particular
instance we do this this cross over at
the point where there are about as many
open nodes as there are features because
that's about the level of parallelism
that the strong branching has and we
just we do a perfect load balance
because each processor is individually
grown these trees and mirror then they
actually know which piece is theirs
without having to do any communication
so it's perfect load balancing no
communication we do this crossover okay
what pebble has the hierarchical hub
worker system so each individual they
have a processor that works as a hub
sometimes as a worker hub has a number
of workers at controls that's a
controllable para controllable parameter
there's also defaults for that and then
the hubs themselves have a tree for
communicating for global information the
hubs only communicate these small tokens
that allow them to locate the data of a
particular problem the bounds just
enough information to allow them to
manage it and then this then the other
workers communicate the heavy amount of
data themselves and what normally is a
fairly random pattern we have a lot of
load balancing it's really important
that you do load balancing because in
the best of worlds you would like your
parallel of computation to as close as
possible match the order in which you
explore nodes in the cereal in the
cereal world normally in the cereal
instance you take the open problem that
has the highest upper bound because
within the bounds of your bounding
function you'll have to explore that
anyway because you can't throw it out
until you open it up and look at it you
don't have any way to know that there
isn't something interesting inside of
that now when you have a lot of parallel
processors all going for a kind of a
small amount of food there in terms of
early nodes they're all going to grab
what's there and they're going to start
growing their own trees locally if you
aren't careful and if you aren't lucky
sometimes you can create an awful lot of
work that would never have been created
in the serial processor and in the begin
of parallel branch-and-bound this could
actually cause slow down where
processors were slower by wall clock
time than the serial process we don't
have that here but you want to be very
careful so we have the hub's can
sometimes pull workloads back from the
processors who keep a local pool to keep
themselves busy the workers when they
create when they when they create new
sub problems will occasionally randomly
scatter them as in the carp load
balancing algorithm and then every once
in a while there's a rendezvous low
bounce where you go up and down the tree
to share quality and quantity of
workload and then you do a rendezvous
where processors that have work to
donate meet up with the processors that
have worked who would like to accept
work and you know the ice donor and the
ice receiver meet at the ice processor
in a rendezvous okay so here of our
experiments we did use the UC irvine
machine learning repository in
particular Hungarian heart disease which
has 249 observations 72 features there's
also the spam data set we dropped the
missing features and the ones that were
real time we partitioned according to
thresholds they have these zeros
followed by one instances and thresholds
are correct if you don't bring two
vectors together that should be
separated we ran on a really big machine
that says each node has eight processors
dual quad-core xenons the big machine
has 22,000 cores on a lot of RAM the
general partition is has a lot of cores
usually need some special permission to
get it we didn't really need it for the
examples that we were doing here we had
128 a larger number of workers per core
because because these are fairly hard
sub founding subproblems so first
example now in the this is the Hungarian
heart and this is the 250 third
iteration in the LP boost algorithm the
first set of experiments are dealing
with was it was it worthwhile to ramp up
or not and so in this particular case
the ramp up is is that is the red and
the non ramp of is a blue so it does
have
does make a difference it runs out of
parallel ISM here at about 200 512
processors but by then it's it's running
in about 10 seconds so it's running fast
enough we see that the number of
subproblems is fairly flat so we're
doing a good job of that load balancing
in the span version we're trying to
classify spam emails we we can paralyze
too much further and we run out it you
know we come off of the the perfect
speed up line a little bit after four
thousand and if you look at the number
of subproblems right around there is
when it starts to go up a little bit so
we are having a little bit of extra work
here okay so in particular the night we
mentioned that ramp up was worth it that
we generally for these problems could
get down to one two three minutes there
was no significant loss between one and
two processors there's not a lot of
parallel overhead going from the serial
to the parallel core in this instance
and there's not a lot of overhead going
from one hub to multiple hubs the next
set of experiments involve parallel
enumeration this is also built into the
pebble core so you can specify
enumeration in four possible ways by an
absolute tolerance by a relative
tolerance by an absolute bound on the
objective and by asking for the K best
so this requires an ability to branch
through if your leaf nodes have more
than one instance you have to be able to
get that out of the way so you can
continue to grow the tree you also have
to be able to do duplicate elimination
if you have a heuristic because you
might discover things from multiple
parts of the tree once you start doing
branch through so we use a hash function
a for each solution to find a processor
that owns it that processor keeps a
repository of solutions and they're able
to check for duplicates in everything
except the K best these can these
repositories everything has to be kept
because you wanted everything within
five percent of optimal if you get a
million solutions that's your problem
you shouldn't have picked five percent
and so you keep these all independently
used to merge served at the end but for
K best you have to do some communication
up and down the tree to keep track of
the cutoff point
we were we're interested in enumeration
for this in particular because remember
this problem we're trying to solve is a
column generation problem for the LP
boost model and normally when you do
column generation if it takes a lot of
effort it's worthwhile finding a bunch
of good ones to add all at the same time
so in this particular instance we find
the 25 best and we added in that tends
to accelerate the boost convergence so
here are the results when you enumerate
on the Hungarian heart problem this
comes off of off of linear speed up a
little bit earlier than it did before
that's that's because the the problem
doesn't happen it didn't get an awful
lot more parallelism their warrant
wasn't a significantly bigger tree and
the communication then the extra
communication for enumeration caused
some trouble but here in the spam 26
because the problems were significantly
harder the communication wasn't a big
problem and we scaled almost all the way
down to eight thousand processors nearly
perfectly so this is all open source
code you can freely download it that
code has the knapsack examples as well
as all the code for the MMA examples and
we'd be happy if people wanted to use
that so thank you very much is there a
notion of distance between solutions I
mean is it possible that you know
2 solutions are all very close to each
other and having distance or something
so they might not add as much to the to
the boosting SS I think that that's an
important open question so right now I
told you the four things that we that we
work that we allow enumeration over
there should be an ocean of diversity
that is a difficult question in this
particular instance you might be able to
do something because Hamming distance
and so forth makes sense but for generic
branch of bound for example million
variable integer programs that's a hard
question but I agree it's something that
you should be able to do